okay so uh I'm not going to say that
catching isn't something we do but it's
a be it's a beginner thing and usually I
I want you to know how to do
it um but it's different from seizure on
contact it's it's actually no seizure on
contact okay so you're driv and I catch
you on the back F how you see and it's
actually one of the
drills you see okay
but like we were doing the EO yesterday
and you try to catch and you can't catch
because the
force just fills the Y do you do you get
that or on the uh
chin I can't C is a iif to shove it
okay what I what I need is the the
variability that you can't drive do you
see you can't drive you can't push me
that allows me
to make it go slow no matter how hard
you're pushing such that someone doesn't
even think you're pushing you see that
um that skill is the same one Whatever
where I I um contact you get it okay and
that skill is different from a
catch okay so that's what we're trying
to do so when when you touch
touch it's it doesn't have to be
around it doesn't have to be straight
and keep you out here either because you
can't pull
you see it it can't come back to me in
other words so a catch comes back to me
but it's external till till it hits the
ground p and the seizure
is is on right at touch so what is on
well when you catch here's where I feel
your Center you see and what we're doing
instead is here I feel your center right
right right when we touch right instead
of no Center still that's the
catch Center touch that's why you can
turn that's also why I can go into you
you
see but it's also why I can move
you towards me it's all from the C so
that's where you want to do we've done
enough catching for tonight okay all
right try